well there is good news to tell you on
the unemployment front tonight the
number of people in our state
filing for unemployment is down the
i-team's david charns is here to show us
what job sectors are growing right now
david yeah brian so this is actually
good news more than 10 000
new workers filed for unemployment last
week that's down about
28 000 we're at 130 000 right now again
this is all since the pandemic began
back
in february and if you look at this
chart here this comes
from dieter and you see these numbers
going down here i can sort of point it
out there
and you see this downward trend and
that's that's really good news in terms
of the recovery that we're seeing again
it's going to be slow
but it uh certainly is happening and
then take a look at this this is where
jobs
are growing right now where the economy
is adding those jobs we have 3 400 new
jobs and trade and utilities that's
retail stores and power and things like
that 700 jobs in education as
kids head back to school whether it's in
person or virtual
but we still have 1300 jobs lost in
hospitality of course
huge in our region though that number
has rebounded a lot since february
analysts tell me these jobs won't be
coming back until the tourists come back
and that's going to take some time so
you've got a big
pool of visitors that are going to be a
little bit
slow and hesitant to come back to las
vegas for obvious reasons and so
that timeline is going to be extended
out a bit until we start to see
you know some greater volume come
through mccarran international airport
and along the i-15
and a good part of travel for events
that just aren't happening right now
take a look at this this comes from
applied analysis
18 percent of travel from our region is
international
sixteen percent is for conventions and
five percent is for special events like
big concerts or games here in vegas
again
that's all not going to start up again
until that starts up again
we're just going to see a slowdown of
this hiring i'm david charns 8 news now